Minnesota freshman congresswoman Ilhan
Omar may be in still more trouble after
fellow Democrats read her latest
comments on the political website Omar
says the hope and change offered by
Barack Obama was a mirage recalling the
caging of kids at the border and the
droning of countries around the world
both on mr. Obama's watch she says he
operated within the same broken
framework as his Republican successor
quote we can't be only upset with Trump
his policies are bad but many of the
people who came before him also had
really bad policies they just were more
polished than he was we don't want
anybody to get away with murder because
they are polished we want to recognize
the actual policies that are behind the
pretty face and the smile of our
response on Twitter quote exhibit a of
how reporters distort words I am an
Obama fan I was saying how Trump is
different from Obama and why we should
focus on policy not politics this is why
I always tape my interviews speaking of
Omar and Ocasio Cortes another
Democratic congressman Dean Phillips
tells Politico quote suddenly an entire
party is being branded by the
perspectives of two of its members who
represent 1% of the caucus